hey youtubers is charlie so really big
comic con stuff happening this week they
announced the schedule for the flash
season 3 all the other DC TV shows
they're basically doing like one right
after the other so here's a breakdown so
comic-con 2016 DC is basically taking
every single TV show that it has on air
not just the ones on the CW there are a
couple new shows like powerless which is
basically like Brooklyn nine-nine with
superheroes so when they do superhero
things just expect it to be really
slapstick I'm sure it'll be really funny
but it's going to be on NBC in what
they're calling all these panels are
special video presentations that just
means each show is going to play the
trailer for the new season that's what
the special video is but there are a
couple pilots that they're screening one
of them is that powerless pilot but
here's the actual schedule and it's a
little bit different from previous years
typically all the biggest TV stuff is on
Friday night now it's on Saturday night
so all the DC TV shows are going to have
their panels like one right after the
other so it's going to start with
Lucifer then they'll do Gotham then
they're going to do Supergirl season two
then there'll be legends of tomorrow
season two then the flash then arrow so
there'll be trailers for all those shows
so of course i'm going to do videos for
all those trailers but I'll also explain
what they teased in the panel's they
usually don't give away spoilers but
sometimes they'll tell you for certain
characters coming on or in the case of
the flash they'll clarify what
flashpoint is going to change about the
universe the biggest question on
everyone's mind i think is will flash
point affect the other shows they will
answer that in no uncertain terms of
comic-con and what I'm expecting is is
that it will affect the other shows a
little bit but it's not going to be a
hard reset for arrow or flash like I'm
going to talk about arrow for a second
so just spoilers from season 4 of arrow
so here we go so there was some
production art that Marc Guggenheim
tweeted out just you know just to tease
people and it was a statue of katie
cassidy as the Black Canary so it looks
like there's going to be a monument to
her in Star City and arrow season 5 so
obviously flashpoint isn't going to
change the fact that she died but really
if it's going to change anything on the
other shows expect them to address it
when they do their big for nye crossover
and that's the other big thing they are
going to haight the out of that and
they'll probably explain a little bit
about how it's going to work
structurally without giving away the
plot so you have Supergirl on Monday
nights
you have the flash on Tuesday nights
arrow on Wednesday nights and then
legends of tomorrow just to society on
Thursday night so you can kind of see
how the four way crossover is going to
work just because there are so many
characters between all four of these
shows don't expect every single
character to go on everyone else's show
really just the main actors are going to
cross over and I'm also expecting them
to clarify where supergirls earth is
going to exist like are they going to
change that or they gotta put her on
earth one with Oliver and Barry they
haven't said exactly which actors are
going to be coming from the shows but
I'm expecting them to bring tyler
hoechlin who's going to be the new
Superman they will probably tease what's
happening with his character because it
is a huge deal that he exists in this
shared universe now what I'm expecting
is they'll keep Supergirl on a different
earth so they don't have to explain why
Barry and Oliver and all the people on
flash narrow have never mentioned
Superman it just feels like it be
simpler at this point but then if they
want they can bring them on during the
big crossover then we'll learn about
Superman then they can change things
down the line that they want to side
note too if they're going to be new
suits like if they're going to
functionally change the arrow suit in
the flash suit next year I know that
people are wondering if the flash roots
going to change they'll probably tease
that at comic-con so like last year they
brought the white emblem flash suit they
brought Oliver's Green Arrow costume and
debuted that so expect them to do that
again they always bring the costumes for
the new season so really just get hype
about the fact that they're going to be
dropping trailers for all the new
seasons the interesting thing that's
going to be different from last year
also is that they're starting to shoot
each season a little bit sooner Comic
Con is happening a little bit later in
the year than it did before so they'll
actually have time to film footage with
the actors like a real deal trailer last
year they hadn't started shooting yet so
when they brought that zoom is coming
teaser it was really an edit of Barry
footage that they just worked up in a
computer it wasn't the actual trailer so
what's going to happen is is they'll
continue to announce stuff that they're
bringing to each of these panels so if
something really big it's an ounce I'll
totally do a video for it but just
remember this is all happening saturday
july twenty third so it's a bad a month
away a little bit less than a month i'm
probably going to have to change the way
i made videos about Comic Con last year
just so that I can do all this stuff
there's gonna be so much stuff it's
gonna be so awesome it's like a really
good problem to have you always want
there to be too much awesome stuff to
talk about but I will be
doing videos for all this stuff and this
is just the DC stuff this isn't even
talking about Game of Thrones any of the
big Marvel panel stuff it's gonna be
amazing on Sunday after it's all over
I'm gonna look like Jon Snow after the
battle of the bastards trying to climb
my way out of that pile of bodies be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
what's going to happen is is when we get
a couple weeks closer to comic-con we'll
have a better idea of exactly what the
schedule is going to be so then I'll do
like a final preview for all the videos
that I'm gonna do explaining what's
going to be happening that weekend so
because I'm so happy with the way a game
of thrones went down this season and all
the comic con stuff they're announcing
right now I'll say congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner i'm going to
double the giveaway so Jebidiah
timeshare you win a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so i can
get your contact details that's just on
the about page and i'll start a new
round of the giveaway now and just
announce the winner to the next time I
post a DC video but the next video I'm
going to do is a captain america WTF
hail Hydra reveal they finally revealed
why Captain America has been Hydra this
whole time so I'm going to do a video
for that so that'll be a little more
comic book centric but I'll explain
what's going on so that will post later
tonight so why you guys wait for that
video to post you can click here to
learn a little bit more about what's
going on with flashpoint in season 3 and
you can click here for my game of
thrones season 7 predictions thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you